10 ايام مرت على زلزال سوريا وتركيا الى
للاسف يعني خلف اكثر من 41 الف قتيل ومئات
الالاف من الجرحى ومئات الالاف من الناس
اللي نزحت من تحت الركام لمكان على الاقل
يكون في يعني اسقف تحميهم حجم الدمار كبير
وصادم وخسائر بالمليارات واكثر من 50% من
المباني اللي ما انهارت في منطقه الزلزال
في تركيا مهدده بالسقوط يعني تخيلوا حجم
الدمار والكارثه وبالنسبه لعمليات الانقاذ
فلا زالت مستمره وما انتهت على الرغم من
مرور اكثر من 200 ساعه من وقوع الزلزال
وامس تم انقاذ عدد من الاشخاص على قيد
الحياه
لينضافوا الى قائمه معجزات الانقاذ في
زلزال تركيا والسوريه
[موسيقى]
عمليات الانقاذ مستمره والامل بالحياه
ووجود ناس احياء مستمر وتجسد في امراه تم
اخراجها بعد 222 ساعه في قهرمان قهرمان
مرعش تركيا
[موسيقى]
الثانيه عمرها 77 سنه سجلت معجزه باخراجها
من تحت الانقاض بعد 212 ساعه
[موسيقى]
في زوجين اتراك كمان تم انقاذهم في كوجالي
وهذولي وثقت الكاميرات قبل ما يطلعوا
محادثه بينهم وبين فريق الابقاد في
اليوم
[موسيقى]
تمام تمام
محمد
[موسيقى]